fallout 4 is a pretty fun video game but
every once in a while you're gonna need
a break I'm what better thing to do on
your break then play a video game
thankfully you've got a goddamn nuclear
powered portable console stuck to your
left arm and despite the horrible
ruination that has befallen mankind the
wasteland is still scattered with video
games for you to play but where are they
and what type of games does a waste
under play while on the commute are
sitting on the toilet at work well I'm
here to tell you there are five games
all based on classic gaming franchises
and in this video I'm going to tell you
where to find them while keeping
spoilers to an absolute minimum all
right here we go number one Red Menace
the first game is going to be available
very early on sometime during the
opening hours you're going to find
yourself walking through vault 111
inside Danforth is a cafeteria that you
can easily walk past don't walk in and
look for a terminal inside this terminal
is a holiday for Red Menace a fall
entirety of the original Donkey Kong
with both boy taking the place of
Mario's previous incarnation jump man
like every game in fallout 4 you can
play it on the terminal or press eject
to keep the holotype in your inventory
great work just got four more tapes left
to go number two atomic command next up
is atomic command a missile command
clone which is also available during an
early quest the town of concord is
located a few clicks from vault 111 and
it's here that you will chance upon
Preston Garvey and his band of
travelling misfits the first time you
meet Preston is in an upstairs room in
the Concord Museum of freedom now this
holotape isn't located in a terminal but
as a cover this for a copy of rope Kofun
magazine located on the desk next to
Preston pick it up and you've got
yourself a pretty neat Missile Command
clone number 3 Zita invaders fans of the
mothership zeta expansion for fallout 3
will be all too delighted to pick up
their copy of xeta invaders space
invaders clone located in diamond city
next time you find yourself in
Valentine's detective agency just look
on the desks for another copy of rogue
Kofun magazine pick it up and you're one
step closer to completing the set number
for hip fall the penultimate game is
another one you'll find during the main
quest at one point you'll wander across
a place called Fort Hagan it's here
you'll find an homage to activision's
classic Atari 2600 game pitfall keep
your eyes peeled for a holotape located
inside the command center and make
sure to collect all the bobbleheads
before the time runs a number five grog
knack and the Ruby ruins and last but
certainly not least is grog knack and
the Ruby ruins a sweet little D&D game
located in the town of good neighbor
like basically all of these tapes you're
gonna pass through it during some stage
of the main quest so while you're in
good neighbor make sure you explore a
building called memory den here you'll
come across another copy of Rob Kofun
magazine with your very own holotape of
grog map and that's it you've collected
all the playable videogame holotapes in
fallout 4 let us know which one is your
favorite in the comments below and of
course fallout 4 is full of these types
of secrets and easter eggs and if like
me you want to discover more of them
make sure you check out GameSpot's
fallout 4 show every week on gamespot
com on YouTube see you around
wastelander
you